hello oh boy
today is the day that the iPad pro was
released I'm actually in New York right
now I have no idea what this video looks
like because I forgot my little monitor
so the only way that I can kind of see
you guys if there's a mirror but you're
so I have to be like this just see in
the mirror to see you
it's really quite silly but I wasn't
home to be able to get my iPad that I
ordered and it's great that I wasn't
home because I actually forgot to
pre-order and I ordered an engraved pen
I ordered the folio pad I ordered a case
I ordered everything except the iPad
because if I thought I had done is
ordered the iPad first then I got
sidetracked by graving my pen and
tweeting and a lot of different things
but I'm here I'm in New York and I got a
chance to see the temporary 5th Avenue
Apple Store and I feel like that 5th
Avenue store has been under construction
for a really long time so anyway I went
in today pretty hyped about it and I
even see myself as this overexposed who
knows I have actually in New York to go
to Good Morning America be sure to look
for me on the show if you watch or if
your mom watches or family that watches
tell them that you know me tell them
that we're friends if you need me to
send a tweet to say that we're friends
to confirm it tweet me I will do that
for you
pencil what did I call that I call it a
pen earlier I'm not sure I'm delirious I
honestly don't know when the last time
was I slept I think the last time I
slept to go over to pax that was a long
time ago the smart Keyboard folio we've
also got some dongles because something
that's pretty exciting about the new
iPad pro is it does feature USB see so
with USB see you can do so many more
things than you could previously with
lightning so you can actually use your
iPad pro judge hard to your iPhone and
you take my shoes off I think it comfy
this is a real chill unboxing and I hope
you enjoy it
I hope I'm even recording I don't even
know since this does feature USB see you
can also use an external monitor
probably should not have returned by it
and just kept it because there's times
like these
you
oh man I love Naboo fighters where was I
we're gonna unbox now I promise you if
you can make him to be with this video
congratulations I meant in my iPad air
video but just in case you missed that
video be sure to go check it out
Jonathan I are doing another giveaway of
either an iPad pro or a MacBook Air
which ever one you guys want in addition
to our iPhone 10 our giveaway so we're
gonna be announcing those winners at the
same time so you're gonna go check it
out check out Jonathan's channel check
out my channel subscribe to both like
our videos and we will be choosing the
winners very very shortly here's the
problem with traveling I don't have a
knife I didn't check a bag so I couldn't
travel with a knife so this is a
knifeless unboxing hope you understand I
hope this is even focus it's cute very
well-being manual focus for all I know
this could be the worst thing that I've
ever done you know that's not true
I've posted a lot of crap on the
internet if you guys aren't already
subscribed to my channel please do so
because I'm working on a really fun iPad
pro video this is just the unboxing but
I really want to test out the
capabilities for actual artists and
creators because I don't really use this
for illustration but I have a friend who
does so he is going to be creating a
really cool illustration for you and
showing you guys how a real creative
artist actually uses an iPad other than
me who watches Netflix and workout
videos and spills Doritos all over this
thing looks so good I thought at the
Apple Store and it's always so cool
going to Apple stores because sometimes
a lot of you guys you don't really know
what to say when you see me there or you
don't think it's actually me so then you
ask questions like hey sorry do you make
youtube videos I'm like yes I am
give me a freaking hug yeah oh good look
at this you look great so this is the
one terabyte version which is absolutely
absurd what am I gonna do with a one
terabyte iPad I'm asking myself the same
question smells like a vanilla spice
latte with a hint of cinnamon wow are
you delicious there's the camera
and if you're completely new here and
haven't seen any videos about the iPad
pro yet this is the 12 point 9 inch
model this is the one terabyte version
and they also have
one with cellular and Wi-Fi I usually
end up just doing things off of Wi-Fi or
tethering with my phone so this is the
Wi-Fi model one terabyte of delicious
delicious storage this features the new
a 12 X Bionic chip there's no home
button so it now does feature face ID so
this really is kind of just like a
really massive iPhone and the screen
looks so good
Quick Start so we have an iPhone or iPad
running iOS 11 or later bring it nearby
all right set me up a be the new Apple
pencil now features gesture control so
if you are an illustrator or somebody
who does those kinds of things I think
it'll be super helpful because you can
switch through brushstrokes and
different things and you don't actually
have to go into menu settings or
anything you just double tap okay let's
set this up to the hotel that I'm in
this hotel is incredible by the way the
Lighting's not ideal for shooting but
everything else is amazing
give me my complimentary Wi-Fi please so
it's saying that it may take a few
moments to activate my iPad don't worry
I have all the moments that you need so
take your time and I'll actually have
that many moments because I'm hungry and
I want to go get dinner so don't take
too much time base I do
setting up phase ID on this massive
tablet how I'm like this is so huge you
can't even imagine what people next door
might think that is happening in here
I just unboxing an iPad if somebody can
hear me don't be concerned okay you set
up my Apple ID I'm going to show them
something else so I'm talking to my iPad
like it's a person
are you surprised what else we have in
the box we've got so I'm what I was
trying to act surprised that I'm not
really good at faking my emotions this
these stickers I actually saw Jonathan
unbox and he made noted how massive
these Dicker's are they are much larger
I feel like then the previous versions I
don't have any with me you compare we've
also got a USBC cable and oh look at
this this looks like all of the charging
bricks that come with all of the Google
accessories but this is an all-new
charging brick I've never seen one of
these from Apple before it's so dark in
here or I'm
but I can't read the voltage on it so
check me into the retirement home
how am I supposed to comfortably show
you this this is so ridiculous I'm
loving every freaking second of it
brightness is turned up so I guess I
should I don't know what to do now
I should probably download procreate see
what else we have so this is their new
keyboard this is something that I would
need my knife for but I don't have one
Julie knives I've had taken away from me
at ESA probably like 14 even had my
tactical knives taken like come on like
let me take that through I'm not gonna
do anything so I ended up getting the
Space Gray one everyone was joking like
we'll just you know how are you going to
survive without not having a bold eye
bad I don't know how I'm gonna survive I
think I'll be okay okay beautiful fancy
hello hanging out here so it has a
little magnetic little docking station
here so that's how it actually stays put
and then it has two different settings
here so there's one if it's on your desk
and here's how that is really in there
that's good that's nice and this second
little setting if it's on your lap well
I think I'm Way more into this iPad that
I thought it was gonna be oh now I'm
like hyped for my flight back there's
gonna be sitting there like can somebody
please talk to me about my new iPad does
I do what I want to talk about it cuz
it's here can we reach back do you want
to be my present here's a little test PC
hello I am typing this feels nice Wow I
like it it's a nice feel yeah I'm into
that it's a nice tight it's a very nice
tight
gosh maybe I'll respond to my emails now
it's down to the pencil this is the
epicanthal to this features gesture
control and you can now magnetically
attach it to your iPad I don't know if
you guys remember well if you have an
iPad and you have an Apple pencil and
you charge it there is no way that
you'll ever forget how you had a
freaking charge that thing like you
would just jam it into the light and
cable at the bottom then you'd have this
pencil sticking out of your iPad it
looked absolutely ridiculous I don't
know what they were thinking I honestly
I'm not sure for whatever reason it
still worked and the Apple pencil is
incredible and I think it's such a cool
device you have a pencil we've got some
paperwork so maybe graded they had a
little mini stickers in here you know I
would be a surprise I'd be shocked I
also got one of these and I got my name
engraved in it I don't know why it said
do you want the free engraving and I
said yes there we go
oh there's still something on this okay
now witness my friends sleeve hug oh wow
that was great look look what it's doing
look it's doing something Apple pencil
Connect yes I want to connect it no way
I'm actually left-handed so whatever so
I have an artist as you can see this is
what I like to call mistakes were made
mm-hmm so if you like prints will be
available I'll put a link in the script
I'm just kidding
I'm not actually actually I probably
should have put this out because it is
the best thing I've ever seen mistakes
were made you probably can't see it I
can't even say it is this video we've
been recording I don't know let's put
that there
god this pens all the time pads really
beautiful this is a USB C 2 SD card
reader so because this is USB see you
now can use usb C dongles accessories
like this and I'm also excited about
this
why did he Capel so long to make a USB C
SD card reader
I don't know well it doesn't matter they
have one now so you can use this to
transfer footage to your iPad pro this
is one of the Thunderbolt 3 USBC cable
so this will be able to transfer data
much quicker and
is this one this is the USBC digital AV
multi-port adapter so this will allow
you to have an additional USB C port and
HDMI and just a regular USB port so this
is actually quite nice and I'm kind of
excited because I can use these with my
macbook pro as I never say no to USB C
dongle ah lucky this I freaking love
technology I love the future where we
are right now is a such an incredible
time because I feel like we're on the
verge of so many incredible things in
the next I might also say the next five
to ten years but even in the next year
car tech they are VR so many amazing
things if you guys stay subscribe to my
channel you may get to see some of it o
else went to the Lego store today I
bought myself a New York luggage tag
just this Lego New York body cuz I
didn't really need anything else I just
thought I'd bring this back home put on
my lego minifigures don't ask so now
with face ID on the brand new iPad on
the iPhone that just leaves the macbook
and the IMAX to also start integrating
face IDs so that's gonna be pretty cool
it's kind of interesting that they
haven't really done that already I mean
it's not that shocking because it
probably would increase the price of
those machines as is I'm so excited to
shoot my more in-depth video with this
it's gonna be really cool and I'm so
excited to share with you from someone
else's perspective on what it's like to
use an iPad and also I want to do some
AR demos so there's so many things that
I would love to do with this so if you
guys have any other suggestions on
things that you might like to see leave
those in the comments below and I will
see you very very very very soon
probably like in a few days because I
have to shoot and edit the video but if
you have to be watching Good Morning
America tomorrow I'll see you there
[Music]